las redadas a gran escala que revelaron
la composición de un grupo de extrema
derecha que pretendía eliminar
reemplazar el estado alemán como lo
conocemos ha vuelto a poner el enfoque
en el movimiento de los highs o
ciudadanos del High como se les conoce
un movimiento que es seguido de cerca
por las autoridades alemanas ya desde
hace varios años y cuyo elemento Central
es que desconocen el estado alemán
desconocen las leyes alemanas desconocen
la Constitución alemana y por el
contrario creen que Alemania es una
entidad similar al imperio alemán que
estaba vigente antes de la Segunda
Guerra Mundial las autoridades alemanas
y en particular la agencia de
inteligencia doméstica consideran que
alrededor de 21.000 personas forman
parte directa o indirectamente de este
movimiento y que tienen un potencial
violento en particular por lo que se
considera es una afinidad a las armas de
hecho el año pasado se registraron unos
mil crímenes relacionados con esta de
los
autoridades presentaron las redadas como
una victoria contra este movimiento pero
ya hay preguntas ya hay un debate en
Alemania sobre qué más pueden hacer las
autoridades para afrontar este gran
desafío de los High spega que se está
volviendo más importante para Alemania